oh
well the strain has just wrapped up his
first season and since i did a review of
the premiere episode i thought it was
only fitting for me to come back
and talk about the first season overall
now to consider this your spoiler
warning because i am going to be
talking about the entire show up to and
including the recently aired season
finale
the short spoiler-free version is that
this show became an exercise in
frustration for me
now i do make an attempt to try and
divorce
my expectations of what i wish something
was and accept it for what it actually
is now i don't always succeed in that
i'll be the first to admit that
and i really was unable to remove
what i'd hoped this show would be from
the final result but i actually blamed
the show for that because it repeatedly
dangled interesting and unique aspects
and plot points
to either immediately ignore them or
yank them away
here's an early example of what i'm
talking about the first few episodes did
a lot of really good
build up and had a lot of tension around
the four survivors
of the plane disaster that was shown in
the pilot one of them in particular
really intrigued me with how his handle
i dealt with this husband
and father and he came home and he was
starting to undergo the physical changes
that you would associate with someone
becoming a vampire
now his wife could tell something was
wrong and she could
just sort of sense that it was dangerous
she arranged for her kids
to be sent off somewhere safe but she
stayed behind she stayed behind to try
and help him
even as he became clearly visibly less
human and just more unhinged with his
own last bit of humanity he locked
himself
in their shed and she even after he's
locked away and he's not even a
semblance of humanity left
she arranges for a neighbor to open that
shed so her husband can feed
this is a phenomenal intriguing
deep heavy setup i mean honestly it's
the sort of thing that could almost
support its own series how far will this
woman go
for the man that she loves even though
he is clearly not that person anymore
well immediately at the start of the
next episode turns out
she killed herself and then the heroes
of the show off the husband and that's
it they move on
and it's just such a waste of an amazing
and intriguing setup i mean i understand
that wasn't the main point of the show
they weren't going to string it along
forever but
they set it up and then literally did
nothing
it keeps hitting these forks on the
roads where it could do something
interesting and dynamic and unusual and
always opts for the obvious cliched
option if you watch my review of the
pilot you may remember what i talked
about ephraim goodweather and how i
really liked him when he was focusing on
this disease and he was working on that
and i was concerned about
the family dramatics with his ex-wife
and his son
taking over his character well take a
wild guess what happened
the guy just gets so bogged down in this
tired very obvious
line of family drama that pretty much
the scientific aspect of his character
gets pretty much
dropped around the fifth episode
altogether and all he does is
argue with the old man who clearly knows
what is going on they in fact
the guy points out to ephraim repeatedly
hasn't everything i said been true yes
it has only an idiot would keep
questioning him what does this guy keep
doing
and speaking of the old man it brings up
another point this show has got the
wrong
main characters the most interesting and
dynamic and
fun characters by far are vasily fett
who's an exterminator he's just a fun
character he's the guy that is the most
enjoyable to watch in these sorts of
scenarios which is that he's not in
denial
he's not gonna go oh my god how could
this be happening he's gonna observe
what's going on and just
roll with it he's gonna do whatever he
has to do to survive he's not going to
question the scenario he's going to just
fight against it right off the bat
and the other really good one is the
character of abraham sutrakian now
admittedly it's a slightly cliched
character in a vampire setup
it's abraham van helsing basically but
he's so well played by david bradley and
given some really phenomenal backstory
from his history as a concentration camp
survivor
that it works it works really well and
actually
this should have been a wake-up call to
the makers of this show because when
your flashback is more interesting than
what's going on
in the main story it's a sign that maybe
you need to work this
a little bit better but they're clearly
not the main characters they're always
side characters our heroes are supposed
to be
ephraim and nora and nora is even
worse than ephram is she exhausts so
much physical and emotional energy
trying to save and then shelter her
mother with alzheimer's hmm i wonder how
this little bit's gonna turn out
exactly how you think it is and hope for
no particular reason nora and ephraim
are
occasionally lovers why because that's
just what happens with your male and
female leads that's what they do
no you don't need to be doing that it
serves no function
serves no point in fact they get caught
by another character who says oh
in the middle of a play do you find time
to get busy on the rug that is exactly
what i was asking
in the way the entire infection unfolds
i never felt like i had a really good
picture
of how this thing was spreading because
how
big or small or where the infection was
located within the city of new york
completely varied from episode to
episode pretty much just depending on
what that episode needed it to be
so you've got some episodes where it
seems like the entire city is just
overrun with vampires you can't get away
with them there's other times they're
almost nowhere to be seen
the place is just like a ghost town and
you get no effective sort of birds out
here like oh there's the heart of the
infection it's spreading out from there
well no it's there
and it's there and it's oh wait but it's
not there anymore because now the
heroes are there and there's no
another example of just doing the most
contrived convenient style of writing
is the limited communications it's a
fairly important plot point that
a group of hackers gets hired to just
bring down the internet in new york city
now setting aside how
plausible that even is in the first
place the show is completely
inconsistent on how effective it is
because there are times when
if the story needs it they can't even
get a text message to each other there
are other times that are actually able
to surf the internet as
normal albeit somewhat slowly just long
enough
to get a vital piece of information then
the internet goes down again
this is the absolute epitome of
contrived convenient
storytelling it doesn't even follow any
kind of internal logic
now again if you saw my review of the
pilot you may have mentioned that i said
guillermo del toro who's one of the
creators and directed that pilot seemed
to be ripping himself off a little bit
specifically borrowing from blade 2.
well change ripping off a little bit to
ripping off
wholesale really this story is blade 2
without blade
the newly effective vampires are handled
pretty much identical
to the reapers in blade 2 down to the
loss of
all body hair the protruding stinger
that is used to both
feed and infect others having vampires
function really more like zombies than
proper vampires heck i'm pretty sure i
even saw
some of those vampires doing the
sideways reaper scuttle
and it's not even just with the vampires
they're ripping off blade too remember
the uv light bombs
they're back sewers infested with
massive nests of vampires yup
check that off the list too now even if
you've never seen blade 2 and wouldn't
recognize
all that stuff that it's ripping off the
show is incredibly repetitive just unto
itself
i lost count of how many times the show
re-emphasizes
the newly infected go after their loved
ones it was made
pretty clear and by about the fourth
episode this was made very clear in the
first few times it was very effective
but it just keeps
hitting that same note again and again
and again
not to mention just the progress of the
infection gets played out repeatedly
again
even though we've seen the entire cycle
by the third or fourth episode
there's another character a gus he has
like a little bit that's actually
relevant in the start of the show and
then
he keeps turning up for no clear reason
well no i take it back the reason is
clear he's going to be important later
on
but in the context of this season the
guy serves absolutely no purpose they
keep touching base and keeping tabs on
him but he's not doing anything that's
giving us any more information he's not
a particularly interesting character
unto himself
first we see his friend get infected we
go through the entire infection cycle
with that and then he gets back to his
apartment his brother's infected oh and
his mother's infected too oh it isn't
landlords in fact oh for crying out loud
we've seen it we
get it setting aside the mindless horde
of vampires our actual main villains are
a bit of a mixed bag too we've got
eichorst who is actually quite effective
he's basically a nazi vampire he factors
in very well into cetrakian's
past and his flashbacks and the actor
just portrays the part very well and
when we see his full vampire
look you know not trying to pass for
human it's interesting it's cool it's
creepy
but he's not the main bad guy the main
bad guy is the master
but the guy's basically just a stand in
for dracula first of all
and they were kind of getting away with
it until they actually revealed him
because
for at least the first half of the show
probably a little more than that he's
just he's this
huge cloaked figure we don't see a face
and it's kind of intriguing then
they finally show him to us and he looks
like this
let that sink in for just a second i
mean they basically took
the vampire design for someone like i
course and did
the saturday morning cartoon version of
it it i
almost did a spit take and burst out
laughing when i saw this thing
it's ridiculous look i'm not enjoying
crapping all over this show i wanted to
like it i
liked the pilot it had such potential
but it just it
it does almost nothing with it you know
there are a few bright spots i mentioned
kevin durant and david bradley as
vasilian as cetrakian they're
golden if the show had focused on them
primarily it would have been a million
times better already
sean aston works well as a very morally
compromised character because he's not
what you'd expect for that so he worked
there's some interesting stuff
particularly that's happening in the
finale
in terms of what we're learning about
these guys they call themselves the
agents we don't really know what's going
on with them they
seem to also be vampires but they're not
digging what the master is doing so it's
like
is he a rogue version from them so like
that's
interesting but i don't know if that's
gonna be enough to get me to come back
next season
but really very much like the walking
dead i feel like
i've seen all this before and it had the
potential to do something much more
interesting
now maybe if you're not as steeped in
vampire movies as
i am maybe it'll be new to you maybe
it'll be fresh to you and it'll be
interesting but for me
who's seen this stuff before it feels
like a retread it's a mashup of a couple
different things but it's all stuff i've
already seen
and it's presented well enough that it
wouldn't frustrate me so much if it
didn't keep dangling more interesting
ideas and then doing nothing with them
so while i am somewhat intrigued by the
stuff with the ancients and where it's
gonna go next season i don't think i
trust this show enough to do anything
interesting with that idea because i've
seen them blow
too many interesting possibilities
already like i said i kind of have to
compare it to walking dead most of the
people i know who really dig the walking
dead are people who have not seen a ton
of zombie
films i have so i feel like i've seen
pretty much everything the walking dead
has to offer me
and i feel the same about the strain so
if vampires are more of a peripheral
thing to you if you haven't seen a ton
of scary vampire movies well you know
what
this may work for you but if you're
anything like me at all there are better
ways to spend 13 hours of your life
so let's try and end this on an upbeat
what is your favorite
scary vampire film or tv show
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
next time this council
is adjourned